and explain the rationale for removing
from the Prime Minister that which every
prime minister has received up until
this point
well no prime minister before has been
found to have misled the House of
Commons and the British people on so
many occasions Boris Johnson is now the
most disgraced former prime minister in
British history uh and while I totally
support the cross-party Privileges
committee's report I think now we look
to the prime minister to show some
leadership Richie sunak has been quite
weak on this
um he's kowtowed to his back benches to
people in the conservative party who
still won't face the facts about Boris
Johnson and Richie sunach should
therefore withdraw this uh lifetime
allowance Boris Johnson will be paid 115
000 pounds a year for the rest of his
life to organize his offices I mean I
just don't think that sits alongside
this report uh he deserves further
punishment for sure
uh you mentioned Rishi sunak there
dining Street continuing to inform us
that he's taking his time to go through
the report and we will have we will have
statement from them at some point but
there has been a suggestion this morning
that for for perfectly normal reasons
the Prime Minister might not be able to
attend at the vote on Monday if Rishi
sunak were to swear of the votes on the
Privileges committee report what would
that signal
well it confirms yet again his weakness
he said when he became prime minister
that he wanted to bring back integrity
and accountability to British government
well he keeps failing and this would be
a massive failure if he doesn't join
parliament in holding uh the former
prime minister Boris Johnson to account
what I would say from the liberal
Democrat perspective is that we should
get this debate on the report out the
way quickly and get back onto the issues
that matter to British people now there
are millions of families and pensioners
who are suffering from the cost of
living crisis their mortgages in
particular now going up massively
liberal Democrats have their opposals to
help people with those mortgages and we
need to get back to those issues you're
not suggesting however that you know
partygate the idea that Insight number
10 officials and politicians were
breaking the rules whilst the rest of us
were stuck at home you're not suggesting
that that doesn't matter to people no it
matters immensely that's why liberal
Democrats have come up with a powerful
sanction that against the Prime Minister
you know all those people who are
bereaved during Kobe those tens of
thousands bereaved families they need to
see Justice and what the Democrats are
putting forward it's a proposal the
Prime Minister was strong enough to to
meet out that Justice to the former
prime minister
um but what I also say is that millions
of people are fed up with this they know
he's guilty let's get on with that vote
that punish him and get on to the issues
that are affecting people's lives and
you know we've seen what's happening the
mortgage Market there are millions of
people out there who are deeply worried
we're already seeing repossessions of
people's homes going up 50 in the last
three months there's a crisis out there
and the government is so chaotic so
divided so focused on the past it's not
able to deal with the huge struggle
facing uh the British people and so
that's why little Democrats they keep
coming forward with positive alternative
proposals and the conservative seem
incapable of dealing with people's
problems sure but you're suggesting
going further even further than the
Privileges committee decided to go but
were you not surprised by the sanctions
that they were going to recommend the
imposing Boris Johnson if he hadn't you
know flying stuff and then decided to
step down as a member of parliament I
mean he got 90 days was going to get a
90-day suspension Margaret Ferrier took
covert on the train with her and she
only got 30.
yeah well I I was pleasantly surprised
uh and a huge credit to this cross-party
a conservative dominated committee for
writing the report they did I think they
spoke for the whole nation uh in making
it clear that
um cross-party uh people believe that
Bryce Johnson is a liar that's what
people have felt but doesn't it doesn't
pass off from his former member has
passed doesn't that just look a little
bit childish doesn't that look a little
bit Petty
no
you know that this man misled Parliament
on a very serious matter there's a huge
insult to uh tens of thousands of people
who were grieving
he passed the laws he had one law for
him and another law for the rest of us
that was one of the worst examples of
failure of leadership at the top of our
country our great country he betrayed
people's trust and therefore um I think
there should be these sanctions now this
committee this we didn't have a little
outcome by the way it was Victorian
labor MPS and I support what they said
and they didn't have many other
sanctions that they could impose so they
imposed the ones they could and what the
Democrats are doing is saying let's
impose an even tougher sanction which
the committee couldn't but Rishi sunak
and the conservative government could if
they had the strength to do it I fear
they don't
um but I am making a second point today
I do want to come back to this because I
think it's really we have literally we
have 15 seconds left on the program so
if you've got can make it in five
seconds do if not
uh Parliament the government should be
helping people with their problems with
cost of living NHS and get rid of this
whole debate about this appalling man
thanks very much